hé, je suis josh trank et je suis simon
kinberg et voici notre ventilation de la
bande-annonce des Fantastic Four, alors restez dans les parages
car nous vous donnons un aperçu exclusif de l'
intérieur, comment avons-nous obtenu cet automne,
les êtres humains ont un désir incommensurable
de découvrir pour inventer  à faire je suis vraiment un
grand fan de Bryan Hitch et de ses oeuvres
et de tout ce qu'il a fait et la grande chose
qui m'a vraiment inspiré de son travail dans
The Ultimates était de voir lu dans un
garage je veux absolument raconter l'
histoire d'un jeune Reed Richards  ouais et
je pense que je pense parce que nous voulions
raconter l'histoire générationnelle et vous l'avez
fait dans Chronicle et nous le faisons dans ce
film sur la prochaine
génération, c'est l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles nous avons examiné les ultimes comme vous le
savez en partie  l'inspiration pour le
film parce que ceux-ci sont plus jeunes,
fantastiques pour vous, rappelez-vous que je vous ai dit que j'en avais
parlé à Stanley et je lui ai en quelque
sorte donné un pas très semblable à un
pitch mais je lui ai juste dit pourquoi je
voulais faire le Fantastic Fo  ur et et il
aimait vraiment l'idée que
quelqu'un prendrait les Fantastic Four au
sérieux comme ça et les placerait
dans un espace moderne qui était vraiment
refroidi, c'est juste un peu ici Stanley, vous
savez que le cosinus de cela
dépend presque de la poursuite de ces idées
un  la responsabilité
qui repose sur les épaules des
générations à venir est Reed
Richards kate mara est sue storm et
Michael B Jordan comme Johnny Storm et
Jamie Bell comme Ben Grimm je veux dire, je ne
pense pas que nous pourrions trouver de meilleurs
acteurs pour les représenter  personnages et
cette version de l'histoire ouais et je
pense que parce que nous voulions être ancrés
dans le dramatique, nous avons opté pour les meilleurs
acteurs dramatiques,
mais à chaque nouvelle découverte
lorsque Jack et Stan ont créé les Fantastic
Four dans les années 60, nous sommes dans le sur le
au bord de la science qui change vraiment physiquement
le monde, tu sais, je pense que de
la même manière que c'était la prochaine
génération qui a envoyé des hommes sur la lune,
c'est maintenant la prochaine génération qui est comme
créer Internet ouais alors la nouvelle
frontière et et je me souviens qu'au
début de ce film, vous vouliez
explorer à quoi ressemblerait cette nouvelle frontière
et faire un film de super-
héros fondé sur la science et la réalité Je
voulais vraiment voir la science et la science-
fiction qui  Je pense que nous
voyons rarement qu'il y a un risque, il y a un sacrifice ouais
ce sera probablement le cadre qui
est gelé et capturé à l'écran et
envoyé par e-mail le plus de tout dans le
teaser, je dirais qu'il était logique d'
utiliser la technologie mocap pour amener Ben Grimm
à la vie et être capable d'enregistrer tous
les détails de l'expression et de l'émotion à
travers la performance de capture de mouvement
parce que Jamie Bell est un acteur tellement formidable
, une chose qui reste la même, ce
sont les yeux de Jamie quand il n'est
pas en mocap et ce sont les yeux de Jamie quand
il n'est pas mocap et les
conséquences c'était votre idée de créer ces combinaisons
qui avaient une véritable fonction scientifique pour elles
et elles les transformeraient ou vous les
tourneriez c  des combinaisons de confinement et ils les
aideraient à contrôler ces pouvoirs
qui étaient vraiment
et Stan Lee et Jack Kirby sont fantastiques
car vous avez quatre personnages qui montent
dans une fusée et vont dans l'espace, ils
rencontrent des rayons cosmiques et cela les
transforme en ce que nous savons maintenant est
Fantastic Four et c'est l'une des
choses que nous avons prises très au sérieux et
il y a une vraie science qui l'explore en ce
moment est cette notion de
voyage interdimensionnel oui soyez prêt pour ce qui arrive
ce qui arrive les réponses c'était le
premier groupe de super-héros le plus important de l'
histoire de moderne  des bandes dessinées et évidemment
il y a beaucoup de responsabilités là-bas,
la chose la plus importante à propos des
Fantastic Four est que c'est un film
sur une famille dont je me souviens la première fois que
j'ai lu un fantastique pour la bande dessinée
ce qui était si remarquable à ce sujet, c'est que
c'était ça  à propos d'un groupe de super-héros
qui étaient cette petite famille de substitution
et que toute la dynamique qui est comme
bon et pad qui fait partie d'être dans un
la famille jouait dans une bande dessinée
et je n'avais jamais vraiment vu ça avant
qu'il y ait évidemment des gens avec des familles
et des bandes dessinées beaucoup d'entre eux ou où c'est
comme le droit secondaire exactement ce que
le noyau des Fantastic Four voit
jusqu'où une famille peut s'étirer sans jeu de mots
destiné à les mettre dans les circonstances les plus
extrêmes et à voir jusqu'où
ils peuvent être étirés et pourtant
revenir ensemble et être plus forts que jamais,
c'est vraiment ce qu'est vraiment le Fantastic
Four